pas le saut dans le vide c'est une
politique avec des projets avec une
europe qui est une agence pour le
numérique
l' agence spatiale une politique de
l'énergie et erasmus le jeu x 2 donc les
apprentis et les jeunes entrepreneurs
ils soient ça c'est la vraie europe
c'est l'europe qui crée des choses qui
développe des choses c'est pas la fausse
europe de monsieur draghi ou des autres
ou six longueurs c'est un coeur et dont
on va parler de teyran qu'on ne pouvait
pas faire l'europe par la démocratie
parce que je ne pouvais pas on va parler
des autres candidats vos concurrents qui
viennent aussi sur le terrain de
l'europe durant cette campagne s deux
d'entre eux notamment à charlotte
justement vous parlez de ceux qui
parlent de la sortie l'euro d'après vous
comme une fin en soi marine le pen
jean-luc mélenchon notamment songe à
faire pression sur l'union européenne
il utilise un mot qui devrait vous
plaire celui du refus de la capitulation
face à l'europe
c'est quelque chose que vous on croit
que c'est pas face à l'europe
c'est une fois ce europe qu'on a c'est
une europe relais de ce monde de wall
street de la city moi je crois qu'il
faut se battre au coeur du système
contre ce coeur du système et ses
intérêts financiers qui sont à londres
qui sont à new york qui spécule à tout
va au lieu de favoriser l'émission de
monnaie pour les peuples la main